i mean the view on the portuguese side
is that they don't think this decision
makes sense they think the case rate in
portugal
is similar to what it is in the uk and
obviously it's a big disappointment for
um the the sector here that have been
waiting and
things have started to get back to
normal waiting for tourists to
arrive but of course the uk government
saying that they want to stop this new
uh mutant variant of the indian strain
from coming into the country they say
the case rate is rising in portugal this
is a decision they had to take very
quickly
but i have to say it hasn't stopped a
lot of the passengers that we've spoken
to this morning
in pharaoh and there is a lot of
confusion i spoke to a hairdresser that
flew in this morning
that didn't actually know that she was
going to have to self-isolate when she
gets back
to the uk and she was quite shocked when
i told her she was very concerned about
what that would mean for her job
i spoke to a girl who was on her hendu
who said that her best friend hadn't
been able to come
on the holiday because of the new
quarantine rules
so there is a huge amount of frustration
but i think most of the anger
isn't so much at the fact that the
portugal is going into the amber zone it
is the speed at which
this decision was made i think there was
a hope
that there would be a waiting list that
there would be more warning lots of
people that i spoke to
flying in from london this morning said
that this if they had had more warning
they would have changed their plans but
because it was today and because the
decisions happening on tuesday the
change is happening on tuesday
they really just don't have time to
change their plans a huge
amount of frustration here but there are
lots of flights coming in there's a
flight coming in from manchester just
now one from stansted
soon after and then on the other side
you obviously have the quarantine rush
a reminder really of where we were last
summer with the rules changing very
quickly
and people very suddenly having to
change their plans and scramble back to
britain